- [Instructor] So we have the graph here
of Y is equal to P of x,
I could write it like
this, Y is equal to P of x.
And they say, what is the remainder
when P of x is divided by x plus three?
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this
and they tell us your
answer should be an integer.
So, as you might have assumed,
this will involve the
polynomial remainder theorem
and all that tells us is that
hey if we were to take P of x
and divide it by x plus three,
whatever the remainder is here,
so we'll say the remainder is equal to k.
That value k is what we would have gotten
if we took our polynomial
and we evaluated it at the value of x
that would have made x
plus three equal zero
or just what would have happened
if I evaluated our polynomial
as x equals negative three.
You have to be very careful there
sometimes people get confused.
They see a positive three
and then they evaluate the
polynomial at the positive three
to figure out the remainder.
No!
If you saw a positive three there,
you would evaluate the
polynomial at negative three
but this should be equal to k as well.
And so what is the remainder when P of x
is divided by x plus three?
Well it's going to be equal
to P of negative three.
P of negative three it looks like
it is equal to negative two.
It is equal to negative
two, so our remainder
is equal to negative
two in this situation.
Let's do another example,
actually let's do several more examples.
Here we're told that P of x is
equal to all of this business
where k is an unknown
integer, very interesting.
P of x divided by x minus
two has a remainder of one.
What is the value of k?
So pause this video again,
see if you can work it out.
All right, well this second sentence
that P of x divided by x minus
two has a remainder of one,
that tells us that P not of negative two
but P of positive two,
whatever x value would make
this expression equal zero.
That P of two is equal to one.
And then we could use this top information
to figure out what P of two would be.
It would be two to the fourth power
minus two times two to the third power
plus k times two squared.
So, times two squared minus 11,
and so all of that, that's
P of two right over here
that's going to be equal to one.
Two to the fourth is 16
and then two times two to the third
that's two to the fourth
again, so it's minus 16
plus four k minus 11 is equal
to one, these cancel out.
Now let's see we can add 11
to both sides of this equation
and we get four k is equal to 12.
Divide both sides by four and
we get k is equal to three
and we're done.
Let's do another example,
in fact let's do two more
because we're having so much fun.
So this next question tells
us, P of x is a polynomial
and they tell us what P of x
divide by various things are,
what the remainder would
be when you divide P of x
by these various expressions.
Find the following values of P of x,
P of negative four and P of one.
Pause this video and see
if you can have a go at it.
All right, so P of negative four,
this is going to be equal to the remainder
when P of x divided by what.
You might be tempted to say x minus four
but they're trying to
trick you intentionally.
This would be the remainder when P of x
is divided by x plus four.
And so they tell us right over here
P of x divided by x plus four
has a remainder of three.
So, it's going to be
three right over there.
And similarly P of one, this
is going to be the remainder,
this is the remainder
when P of x divided by
not x plus one, but x minus one.
So when P of x is divided by x minus one,
the remainder is zero.
Let's do one last example.
So once again P of x is a polynomial
and then they give us
a few values of P of x.
And they say what is the remainder
when P of x is divided by x minus three?
Pause the video and try
to think about that.
Well, we've gone over this multiple times,
the remainder when P of x
is divided by x minus three
that would be P of not negative
three, P of positive three.
Whatever value of x makes this
entire expression equal zero.
So P of positive three is equal to five.
And similarly what is the remainder,
actually not so similarly,
this is interesting.
What is the remainder when
P of x is divided by x?
I know what you're thinking
it's like wait what
number am I dealing with?
But if I were to rewrite this
instead of saying divided by x,
if I were to say divided by x plus zero
then you'd be like oh now I get it.
Or if I wrote divided by x minus zero,
you'd be like oh, now I get it.
This is going to be P
of and it doesn't matter
whether I take a positive
or a negative zero,
it's going to be P of zero.
And P of zero, they tell us,
is negative one and we're done.